Equifax is facing new legal trouble over
its massive security breach the city of
San Francisco is suing the credit
reporting agency over the hack that
exposed the personal information of a
hundred and forty three million
Americans that news follows the sudden
retirement yesterday the company's CEO
Anna Werner is in San Francisco where a
company is offering to help customers
follow their own lawsuits in small
claims court and a good morning good
morning well if you're a victim of the
Equifax hack how do you get justice you
may be eligible to join a class-action
lawsuit but a start-up here in San
Francisco says they have a better idea
they'll help you file your own claim so
you can take Equifax to small claims
court Equifax hack victim Devin McGehee
is a legal assistant
but even so says he found the idea of
going to small claims court against
Equifax a little intimidating until he
found the company legalist McGehee filed
court papers already filled out by the
company which also paid his ninety
dollar filing fee I thought it was
unique I thought it was bold I thought
it was kind of a good way to shake up
the legal industry you're one of the
hacking victims I was legalist
co-founders Eva Shang and Christian Haig
usually finance lawsuits on behalf of
small businesses and individuals
providing capital until a case pays off
it was incredible to me that a company
the size of Equifax could be so
incompetent and negligent with consumers
data they say Equifax presented a chance
to make a statement the message is that
big corporations do not have a free hand
over our personal data do you want to
see Equifax fighting literally thousands
of these lawsuits in small claims courts
around the country is that part of your
goal that is the goal so legalist pays
the court fees and if you lose you don't
even have to pay them back the catch if
you win legalist gets 30% of anything
won but do consumers need to pay for the
help if people want to make the choice
to file small claims cases they can go
ahead and do that they don't need any
assistance rod Weissman heads consumer
group Public Citizen
he says better than small claims are
class-action lawsuits against Equifax
which can be brought on behalf
of all victims and force companies to
change making Equifax do things going
forward to do a better job of protecting
its data so that people don't get
subjected to this kind of injury in the
future those are the kinds of things
that class actions do and do really well
and they're things that small claims
court or individual cases don't but
legalist continues to sign people up
people are starting to realize that they
have more power than they think they do
well legalist says it's had about a
thousand applications so far
we asked Equifax for its response to all
of this the company told us it can't
comment on pending litigation and says
right now it's just focused on trying to
help consumers who may have been harmed
Gail
a lot of people apparently have been
harmed thank you very much Anna